[MUSIC PLAYING]
JIA LI: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jia.
Here today, I'm talking
about how, at Cloud AI,
we're inspired by
customer needs.
AI has the potential to
change every industry,
from transportation to health
care, from retail to education.
However, there is a big gap
between what's possible with AI
and what's within reach
for our customers.
This gap reveals a lack of
awareness on both sides.
On one side, many
traditional companies
lack an understanding of
AI, which makes it hard
for them to benefit from it.
Machine learning development
is an extremely complex cycle.
From collecting data, designing
model, tuning model parameters,
updating the model, evaluating
it, and iterate the process,
every single step would require
machine learning expertise.
Unfortunately, of the world's
21 million developers,
only one million or so have
data science background.
And thousands of them have
deep learning or machine
learning expertise.
And on the other
side, technologists
who are driving the
development of AI
lack an understanding about
traditional industries.
As a result, many problems
that could benefit from AI
remains unsolved.
At Google Cloud, we're trying to
bring our customers and the AI
experts together on
the shared platform.
We try to help our customers
to understand AI and make
its capability more accessible.
Through this
process, we developed
the first-hand understanding
of their world,
the challenges they are facing.
And by combining this with
the AI expertise at Google,
we can address their problems
in powerful new ways.
By understanding
the diverse range
of needs in today's
enterprise environment,
we're delivering the
power of AI in the form
that we hope to meet our
customers where they are.
We provide AI technology across
a wide spectrum of solutions.
On one side, for the
most advanced machine
learning experts, we provide
the most powerful machine
learning tools for them
to build their vision,
like TPUs, TensorFlow, Kubeflow,
Cloud ML Engine, et cetera.
On the other are the customers
who understand the value of AI,
but don't have the
expertise to put it in use.
For them, we offer simple tools
that deliver immediate results,
like the Machine Learning APIs.
And in between, we offer a
growing range of solutions
that blend the ease of use and
sophisticated capabilities,
such as Contact Center
we announced yesterday.
Furthermore, we believe in
delivering maximum results
for every customer,
regardless of their expertise.
Consider Cloud TPU,
for example, the custom
chips that dramatically
accelerate machine learning
tasks.
With minimal amount
of code, advanced user
can run their TensorFlow
models on TPUs
and experience an
immediate boost.
But even novices can rely
on the performance boost
from the latest Google hardware,
as APIs like Translation API
can automatically leverage
TPUs behind the scenes.
No matter what's
your level of scale,
we want to ensure you
benefit from our most
powerful technology.
We call this democratizing
AI, but there's
much more we can do to
make AI more accessible.
To explain where our
technology is going next,
I'd like to share a
bit of the history
that I've witnessed in my own
career in computer vision.
Image classification is
among the greatest success
stories in our field.
In recent years, it has
been going through a lot
of significant improvement.
And now, we're thinking
about how do we
expand the success of image
recognition to other areas?
But we are facing a lot
of challenges in doing so.
The first challenge is data.
Years were spent collecting
millions of images
to train algorithms to
understand what they see.
The second is
algorithm development.
It took hundreds of
researchers decades
to refine the algorithm
behind this single goal.
A big part of democratizing
AI will be finding better ways
to replicate what has made image
recognition such a success.
This is the promise of AutoML.
AutoML makes it possible to
customize our most advanced
machine learning models to your
customized and specific use
case, all without writing
any machine learning code.
Our first release
came earlier this year
in the form of Cloud
AutoML Vision, which
makes it possible to train the
Cloud Vision API to recognize
entirely new image categories.
Keller Williams Realty
is using AutoML Vision
to bring to market the
most advanced home search
experience for consumers.
By training a custom
model to recognize
common elements of
furnishing and architecture,
customers can automatically
search home listing photos
to find their specific preferred
features, like granite counter
tops, or even more general
style, like modern.
And here at Next, we
have introduced two
additional AutoML features--
AutoML Natural Language
and AutoML Translation.
With AutoML natural
language, customers
can train custom models
to accurately recognize
domain-specific
content in their text.
For example, in one of our
customer, Hearst Newspapers,
they're one of the
world's largest publishers
of magazines and newspapers.
They have been always
looking for better ways
to manage their content.
At Hearst Newspaper,
they are looking forward
to leverage Cloud ML,
AutoML Natural Language
to customize domain-specific
text models for their newspaper
accountant.
And that has been providing
high accuracy for their needs,
without writing any
machine learning code.
AutoML Translation helps to
recognize jargon and terms
specific to your domain.
And the result is
actually to translation
to capture the
context and nuance
that your customer will expect.
So customers all
over the world have
been finding ways to improve
translation with AutoML.
For example, Nikkei, a media
company based in Japan,
is evaluating AutoML for
translating international news
articles.
By leveraging AutoML, it
meets the customization
needs from them.
And they have been very
impressed by the accuracy.
AI is still a very
nascent space.
And we know that each of you
face some unique challenge.
We are eager to learn
them and help solve them.
That will require us to keep
a close conversation with you.
Let's talk about the
problems in your industry
and what are the ideal
outcome look like.
And let's work together to
use the latest AI technology
to make that vision a reality.
Thank you.
Now, I'd like to welcome
Stefan to the stage
to share how we are
partnering with SAP to bring
AI and enterprise software to
the physical world using Google
Cloud.
Thank you.
STEFAN NUSSER: Thanks, Jia.
[APPLAUSE]
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Stephan Nusser,
I'm product manager
for Cloud AI in Europe.
Here at Google Cloud, one
of our primary objectives
is democratizing AI, lowering
the barriers to entry
and making it as easy as
possible for customers
all over the world to put its
remarkable capabilities to use.
As AI becomes more
accessible, other technologies
benefit as well.
We see an opportunity here to
use the combined power of AI
and the Cloud to make automation
more accessible to industry
and to businesses of all sizes.
To understand how, let's
take a look at [NON-ENGLISH],,
Industry 4.0, and the
state of automation today.
There's an exciting
transformation
on the way in the
industrial sector.
Manufacturing operations
and the entire supply chain
are being digitized.
This is known as Industry 4.0.
It involves sensorizing machines
and also the environment.
Industrial sector
companies want to use
that sensor data to drive
machine learning and AI.
This promises to enable
new levels of optimization
and learning.
The ultimate goal is to make
processes that are currently
manually operated be controlled
much more efficiently.
Automation plays an important
part in this process.
Now historically, automation
has been highly customized
in silos with high
upfront costs.
And as a result of
that, vendor lock-in.
It's also inflexible.
If you can afford
automation, you'll
structure your entire
environment around it.
Today, we're seeing exciting
trends in automation.
Collaborative
robots, like the ones
shown on this slide
that are equipped
with modern sensors and open
software layers that are easier
to program, these
collaborative robots
promise to transform how we
do automation, especially
in less-structured environment
where these robots can
work side-by-side with humans.
So how do we digitize
the physical world
in less-structured
environments, like the warehouse
that you see on this slide?
It's easy to capture sensor
readings from big machines,
but it's much harder
to digitize goods
in storage or containers of
goods, like bins, or pallets,
or shelves, or boxes,
especially if human workers are
in the same workspace and
manually move these goods
and containers around?
We believe we can solve
some of these challenges
with the help of
collaborative robots
and by harnessing the
power of AI and the Cloud.
And we're not the only ones
who see this opportunity.
Let me tell you a little
about our partner, SAP.
SAP is the world leader in
enterprise applications.
They manage business processes
of large and medium-sized
companies across the world.
Think orders, parts,
or inventory levels.
Their roots are in Europe
and in the industrial sector.
SAP is working with
their customers
to gradually transition
workloads from on-premise
to the Cloud.
That, combined with their
deep industry expertise,
makes them a unique
and strong GCP partner.
Industry 4.0 is a huge
opportunity for SAP
to optimize not only
business processes,
but to take this optimization
closer to the physical world,
based on, for example, real
time awareness of good, pallets,
or trolleys in a warehouse.
Shorter feedback loops
combined with readily available
automation will translate
into increased efficiency
and agility for SAP's customers.
To capture this opportunity,
SAP is looking for ways
to manage and orchestrate
collaborative robots
from different
vendors and to tap
into insights about the physical
world for better optimization.
The Cloud AI engineering
team in Munich, in Germany,
is working on an
open Cloud Robotics
platform that adds
critical infrastructure
for collaborative robots.
It builds on mature
GCP technologies
and provides
foundational capabilities
for Cloud-enabled
automation solutions.
Our Cloud Robotics
platform securely
connects robots with the Cloud.
It enables distribution
of software
and other digital
assets to the robots,
using Kubernetes containers.
It provides infrastructure
for collecting log data,
for uploading it, monitoring
it, and creating dashboards
using Stackdriver.
It also provides infrastructure
for sensor data collection,
aggregation, transfer
to the Cloud,
and processing without data
management biplanes, Bigtable,
BigQuery, Dataflow, and more.
Our objective here is to solve
these common infrastructure
problems for the
entire industry.
Our Cloud Robotics platform
will be open source
and will be built on open APIs.
We'll also provide the
interfaces needed for customers
to port their data
to other platforms.
So there's no window locking.
This Cloud Robotics
platform will
be available to early adopters
at the beginning of next year.
On top of this
infrastructure, we
will offer Cloud services
that leverage our AI platform
and solve several
critical customer pain
points for the mission
with collaborative robots.
Our SLAM service uses
data from sensors,
like lighters or depth cameras.
It allows robots
to create a map,
localize themselves
relative to that map,
and recognize static landmarks.
We further analyze that sensor
data to discover walls, doors,
shelves, tables, chairs,
and other essential elements
of the robot's workspace.
Using that same data, we can
also discover known objects
in their pose in the workspace.
This would allow the
robot to detect and plan
operations on these items.
Where are we going with this?
There is a broader vision here.
Our infrastructure enables
reusable assets on the robot
and in the cloud.
It can support not only the
services I just described,
but also serve as a foundation
for third-party software.
Our plan is to work
with our partners
to grow this platform
into an ecosystem,
using an app store for
easy software distribution.
SAP as a developer,
and their customers,
benefit from easier
creation and deployment
of robotic automation solutions.
They'll also be able to tap into
Cloud-based analytics of sensor
data to expand their awareness
of the physical world.
With this platform,
we're enabling developers
to build innovative, reusable
software and services
for whichever use cases or
verticals they want to tackle.
This will ultimately make
automation drastically simpler
and reduce the cost
of custom integration.
It'll also allow
one-off processes
to be automated seamlessly
through the orchestration
of existing hardware
and software components.
Collaborative robots and
more accessible automation
will complement
local physical labor
and increase productivity
where needed.
This is how automation and AI
can enhance human skills right
here in local labor markets.
Now, please welcome
Rajen Sheth, Director
of Product Management, who's
seen this principle in action
every day.
[APPLAUSE]
RAJEN SHETH: Hi, everyone.
So you heard a lot about the
great technology that we have.
And what I want to talk
about a little bit more
is how customers
are approaching this
and how you can think
about approaching this.
So what you've
seen is that there
is a spectrum of technologies,
as Jia has mentioned.
And really, what
the trade-off here
is the flexibility that you
have versus the ease of use.
And so what we're
really trying to do
is give you a variety
of options so that you
can do many different things.
And I want to explain
this a little bit
and talk a little bit about how
our customers are using this.
So on one hand, you have
our cloud TPUs, which
are very, very, very powerful.
And many of our services
are underlied by Cloud TPUs.
But we're now providing
access for people
that do have a lot of
machine learning expertise
to be able to utilize that to
do some pretty amazing things.
Beyond that, you have TensorFlow
and Cloud Machine Learning
Engine where you can
build your own models.
Beyond that, you
have Cloud AutoML,
which can do a variety
of things to be
able to customize our models.
And then, you have
our APIs, our building
blocks that you
can bring together
that are Google's
models where we're
bringing the best of
Google's technology.
And all of these
let you actually
really add great value.
And I think one thing that's
there is that we shouldn't
mix ease of use versus value.
There are a lot
of things you can
do by just calling our APIs
that give you a ton of value.
And we'll talk about
that a little bit.
So we'll start at the TPU end.
A great use case
for this is eBay.
And this is something that
they've recently been doing,
which is they want to be able
to do visual product search
and do this across a variety of
different types of categories
in many, many different
types of image.
And so they had 55
million images in there
in their training product set,
and they have 1 billion product
listings to search for.
And so they use Cloud TPUs.
And Cloud TPUs are very, very
good with image recognition.
They increased their
image recognition accuracy
by 10%, which is a huge
difference for them
and makes a huge difference
in their business.
But then they also increased
their speed-up time
and training time by
100x by using Cloud TPUs.
Now, going with
TensorFlow, there's
a lot that you can
do with TensorFlow.
It gives you a lot
of flexibility.
And a great example
of this is Ocado.
Ocado's done a variety of
things with our products.
But in one case, they were
using this for fraud detection.
And they built a TensorFlow
model for fraud detection.
Their the UK'S
largest online grocer,
and there are lots
of transactions
happening all of the time.
And so they need to be
able to detect fraud.
So using TensorFlow, they were
able to get a 15x increase
in fraud detection precision.
And this is just
one of many things
that they could
potentially do to help
automate their business.
Now looking at
AutoML, I think one
of the biggest
things with AutoML
is that you can
have customers that
don't have a lot of expertise
in machine learning do
really, really powerful things.
And a great example
of this is Blum.
So Blum is a European
manufacturer of furniture.
And they have hinges that are
of all kinds of different types.
So they were able
to use AutoML to be
able to look at these hinges
and classify these hinges.
They have no in-house
ML expertise,
and they've never used GCP.
But in five weeks, they
were able to create a model
with 91% accuracy.
Now, we talked a little bit
about the building blocks.
And this is a lot of where
Google has brought our best
technologies to bear.
And one of the most powerful
ones is translation.
And so I'd like to welcome up
Adela Quinones from Bloomberg
to talk to us about how they
have been using the Translation
API.
[APPLAUSE]
So Adela, can you tell
us a little bit more
about Bloomberg and
what Bloomberg does?
ADELA QUINONES: Sure.
So Bloomberg is a financial
media and technology company.
We're a news organization.
You might have seen Bloomberg
Television or Bloomberg Radio.
And a lot of people
think of us that way.
But at our core, we're
really a technology company.
We have 19,000 employees
globally, 5,500 of which
are engineers.
So that's a quarter of
our company in engineering
and we a lot of expertise in
machine learning that we really
focus on solving proprietary
problems, problems
around finance and data.
And so we're really
focused on those use cases,
from a technology perspective.
RAJEN SHETH: Makes sense.
And what was the problem
that you were facing
where you used our products?
And how were you
solving it before?
ADELA QUINONES: Yeah.
So our newest product ingests
about two million stories
a day.
We bring in content that
we produce ourselves,
about 5,000 stories
a day, and also
content from premium
providers, like the "New York
Times", and the
"Washington Post",
and also social
media, like Twitter.
So it's a lot of content
coming to our systems.
And for our clients,
milliseconds matter.
A few milliseconds can
make the difference
between a great investment
and a not-so-great investment.
And so we wanted to
make that content
available to our clients in
real time in the language that
was most relevant to them.
News is local.
It breaks in local
language, and we
wanted to be able
to make the content
available in the language
that our clients understood.
So I'll give you an example.
When the municipal bond crisis
was happening in Puerto Rico,
there were reporters
in the courtroom
taking notes and publishing
stories and tweets in Spanish.
Not a lot of our
clients speak Spanish,
so we needed to be able
to make that content
available to our
customers in English
or their native language.
RAJEN SHETH: That makes sense.
And because they
were in Puerto Rico,
you could increase the speed of
getting that content directly
to your clients.
ADELA QUINONES: Exactly,
we wanted to really narrow
the time from when
a piece of news
is available in any
language, and we
make it available to
the client in a language
that they can understand.
RAJEN SHETH: Makes sense.
And so how did Google
Cloud help you solve this?
ADELA QUINONES: Yeah.
So in 2015, we
looked at what was
available from a
translation perspective.
And we really wanted
to find a partner that
could scale, because we
have a lot of content, that
could operate at great speed,
because our own requirements
are hundred milliseconds or
less, from the time the news is
published to the time we
alert our users about it,
and that could also
produce translations
in lots of different languages,
because we're seeing growth
all over the world.
And we want to be able
to support and think
about our future.
And Google really checked all
the boxes on all three fronts.
And I think another
really nice-to-have
was the fact that it was so easy
to work with the Google team
and to connect to
the Google API.
So from the moment
we decided we wanted
to integrate with Google
to the moment when
it was available
on our system, I
think it was less
than two weeks time.
So it was a pretty
remarkable turnaround.
RAJEN SHETH: Makes sense.
And you touched on
this a little bit,
but why Google versus
other alternatives?
ADELA QUINONES: Yeah.
I mean I think, for one, the
quality of Google Translate
was really high.
We integrated Google translate
in 2015, before neural network
translation was introduced.
And at that point, we found that
the quality in many languages
was very, very good.
And in some cases, it was
good enough for [INAUDIBLE]..
And then when Google introduced
neural network translation,
that really changed the game.
The quality was just
really, really great.
And it allowed us
actually to expand
our use of Google Translate
beyond just on-demand news
translation to other
types of news translation.
RAJEN SHETH: Makes sense.
Great.
Well, we really,
really appreciate that.
And it's a very great story.
ADELA QUINONES: All right.
Thank you.
RAJEN SHETH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So part of what we're
really focusing on
is not only helping customers,
but also, in that vein,
doing good with AI.
And so I'd like to
welcome up Fei-Fei Li,
our chief scientist, to
talk to you about how
we're doing good with AI.
[APPLAUSE]
FEI-FEI LI: Good
afternoon, everyone.
So the progress of AI
has been breathtaking.
At Google, we are
all in in trying
to build good AI technology
and products to deliver
to all of you so that it
can make a positive impact.
I want to close today's
session by talking about some
of our shared
responsibilities of AI
and how to make it a
benevolent technology.
You already heard so
much about our efforts
in different aspects
of our technology
development, our products,
and across the globe.
So it's not only
just an aspiration
that we believe a technology
like this should bring
benevolent impact to
our human society,
it's also something we
are putting in action.
So I want to share with you some
of the actions we're taking.
To start with, let's just look
at an AI for A good example,
particularly helping all of
us to protect some of our most
precious natural resources.
So the World Wildlife Fund
and the government of Nepal
have built a network
of cameras to track
endangered animals, like tigers
and rhinos, in the world.
But they are really
easy to miss.
These animals don't
come out so fast.
So they only come out
sometimes a few seconds.
So considering there are dozens
of cameras all rolling at once,
it's a lot of work for humans
to manually monitor all of them
and try to detect, and track,
and spot these animals.
That's where machine
learning can help.
I'm now going to
show you two videos
to demonstrate how generic
object tracking and detection
technology can help to
automate and assist this very
difficult and tedious process.
You're going to see a tiger
is walking out of the fog.
And then, as it comes
closer to the camera,
a machine learning generic
object detection algorithm
will call out
where the tiger is.
So I feel this
tiger looks hungry.
OK, this one impressed
me, because the first time
I looked at it, I didn't
even see the rhino coming out
of the bushes.
Again, it's quite small and
in a very, very cluttered
environment, but where our
generic object detection
algorithm was able to spot the
rhino, even if part of the body
was being occluded, and it's
going to a different angle,
and becoming
smaller and smaller.
So it just warms my heart
that machine learning can do
this for our natural resources.
I don't know how many of
you were at Diane's keynote
yesterday.
She mentioned that
one of her friends
was doing wildlife
preservation in the oceans.
And today, we are bringing
Professor Janet Mann
onto the stage to share with
us the story of her work,
collaborating with
Google Cloud AI,
on preserving wildlife in ocean.
Welcome, Professor Janet.
[APPLAUSE]
JANET MANN: Oh, I need that.
[LAUGHS] Thank you.
Thank you, it's a
delight to be here.
So you just heard about
identifying species
using AutoML.
I'm going to talk about
identifying individual animals,
tracking wildlife using ML.
So tracking individuals is
a critical part of biology
because natural selection
acts on the variation
between individuals.
It's also important for
conservation and management.
And it also appeals
to the public,
in terms of their attraction
to individual animals
and interest in them.
A poignant and sad example
that you are probably
all familiar with was the Free
Willy, also known as Keiko,
where people spent over $20
million on a lost cause,
really, to introduce
him to the wild.
At the same time,
the killer whales off
the coast of Washington
State and British Columbia
have been declining and are
on the verge of extinction.
So you can use the
individual to engage people.
So this was an example
that wasn't very good,
but it shows how important
the individual is
in understanding these animals.
So there's lots of species that
can be tracked through time--
chimpanzees by their
faces, zebras by stripes,
and cheetah by the
stripes on their tails,
manta rays by the spots on
their bellies, and whale sharks
also by their spot patterns,
and even toads by the gland
markings on the Wyoming
toad on their backs.
So these are individually
distinctive, but stable
through time.
How about individuals
that change through time?
So elephants, they are
identified by their ears.
And the tears
change through time.
Sperm whales by
their tail flukes--
and actually, most whale
species by their flukes.
And those patterns
change through time.
And Risso's dolphins by the
scarring and dorsal fins.
So for over 30 years,
I've been studying
dolphins in Western Australia.
Pretty far, remote place.
And we've been tracking
their residential population.
And we've been tracking over
1,700 individuals from birth
to death.
They just live there.
This is Bytefluke.
And as you can see,
her fin has changed.
It is called Shark
Bay where I work.
And so the dolphins do
get bitten up by sharks,
and their fins do
change over time.
Bytefluke, by the
way, 10 years ago
had a calf that we named Google.
And Google is still
alive and well.
He's 10 years old, figuring
out who his friends are.
And then, here's Zombie,
a daughter of Phantom,
born in 2011.
And as you can see, Zombie's
fin changed quite dramatically
in four years.
So we know these animals,
and we can track them.
And basically, how do you track
animals that you don't know?
So I'm going to take you to
another part of the world,
but first I want to say,
we gave tens of thousands
of photographs to the
Google AutoML team
to help us build something
that could track animals
that we know a lot less about.
So that was the
training data set.
And so take it to the other
side of the world-- trhe
Potomac Chesapeake.
Yes, there are dolphins
in the Potomac.
And because it is
the Potomac, we've
named them after presidents,
vice presidents, founding
fathers, first families.
So this is Hubert
Humphrey, who we've seen
for three years in the Potomac.
And to find out where
these animals go,
because they're only there for
about six months of the year,
we want to see
where they winter.
And fortunately, scientists
have been collecting dorsal fin
photographs from animals all
over the Western Atlantic.
And so this is put together
in the Mid-Atlantic,
Bottlenose Dolphin Catalog.
And so our challenge
was, could we
match the Potomac
Chesapeake dolphins
to these other locations.
So I'm going to show you
an example, using AutoML.
And this way, we could
get critical problems
in their biology.
So this is George
Mason, who was one
of the key authors in
the Bill of Rights,
in case you're interested.
But he was photographed in
the Potomac in 2015, 2017.
This is what it looks like.
So we ran the image
through AutoML,
and we tested it against the
Mid-Atlantic Bottlenose Dolphin
Catalog.
And as you can see here,
the first two that came up
were actually George Mason.
And he was seen off the
coast of North Carolina
in 2008 and 2010.
So this is a 10-year
difference, practically,
from when this animal was seen.
And this is how
effective this has been.
So Google AutoML has enabled us
to identify individual dolphins
in seconds.
And to do this-- we usually do
our matching by eye for animals
that we know.
But for animals
that we don't know,
we can use this
technology to map them
onto animals in other
locations and track
migrating individuals.
And this informs us a
lot about the populations
for conservation purposes.
So I want to thank Google
AutoML for helping us with this.
And I'm going to give the
stage back to Fei-Fei.
Thank you.
FEI-FEI LI: Thank you, Janet.
[APPLAUSE]
That is just amazing.
It's not the first
time I saw it,
but my heart is beating when
looking at the amazing result.
So we spent the past two
days sharing with you
our excitement about how AI
can empower industries, make
life work better, when
it's applied right.
But the power does
demand responsibility.
And it is our collective
responsibility
to make this a
benevolent technology.
Earlier this year, Google
published AI principles
to guide our company's
work and development of AI
to do the things that
we believe are important
and adhere to our values.
So today, I'm going
to welcome onstage
two colleagues of mine who will
share a conversation with you,
with us, about how we can
develop responsible AI,
both at Google, as
well as inviting you
to this dialogue about why
it's important to all of us
in the enterprise business
about developing responsible AI
technology.
So please, Tracy and Shannon.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm going to start
with Shannon, AND
I'm going to read her
bio, word by word,
because this is
really impressive.
So Professor Shannon Valor
is a technology ethicist
and a McAdam professor
of philosophy
at Santa Clara University,
where she has taught since 2003.
Shannon has expertise in
ethical implications of AI
and robotics.
She serves on the
board of directors
of the nonprofit Foundation
for Responsible Robotics,
is a member of the IEEE
global initiative on AI,
and has received
multiple awards.
She's the author of 2016 book
from Oxford University Press,
"Technology and the Virtues--
a Philosophical Guide to
a Future Worth Wanting".
And I'm so excited
to announce now
that Shannon has
joined our Google Cloud
team to work with us in terms
of developing responsible AI.
So welcome, Shannon.
SHANNON VALOR:
Thank you, Fei-Fei.
[APPLAUSE]
FEI-FEI LI: And sitting next
to Shannon is Tracy Frey.
I have to say, Tracey is one
of my favorite colleagues
at Google.
I'm not just saying this
because we're on stage,
but her energy, her sense
of moral responsibility,
and her expertise
in understanding
the problems, and
the challenges,
and opportunities that AI
can bring to our customers
is just phenomenal.
And she is our Cloud AI's
go-to-market strategist.
So we don't have a
whole lot of time,
but we're going to have a
conversation here with you
and hope to open that
conversation for many years
to come in this journey
together about the importance
of this topic.
So I'm going to
start with Shannon.
Why does ethics of AI matter
to any company, including
enterprise companies?
SHANNON VALOR: Well,
I think you have
to recognize that
public trust is
one of the most important things
that any corporation needs
to think about, needs to earn.
And public trust in technology
is on a shaky foundation
these days.
And so lots of
companies are having
to think about, OK,
well, how do we cultivate
and build up that public trust
in technology in a way that's
sincere and earned?
And I think that one
of the things that we
have to recognize is that
we've been, for a while,
in a reactive mode where we
see ethical issues that crop up
in society as a
result of the way
certain technologies are
developed or deployed,
and then we jump in
and try to fix it.
But what we really
have to do is step back
and start getting into a more
anticipatory mode where we're
seeing the road ahead
a little bit, where
we're thinking about where
the problems will crop up.
And we do this in all
other kinds of engineering,
and technology, and development
with other kinds of issues,
thinking ahead about where you
might have some stress points
or where you might have
some complications.
So now, we just have to
bring the ethical expertise
into that process.
FEI-FEI LI: Great.
Yeah, so turn a
reactive understanding
to a proactive
action of embedding
ethical and responsible
principles into the AI
and technology.
So to go a little more
concrete, because we
want to actually turn
that into action,
what are the key ethical
principles for an enterprise
company who is practicing AI?
SHANNON VALOR: Well, I think
one of the things you have
to think about are what are
going to be your stated goals
and values?
And right now, I
think, especially
given where the
public trust is right
now and public confidence, I
think fairness and transparency
have to be two of the stated
goals of any enterprise,
of any organization that wants
to earn the public trust.
And then, I think you also
have to think about values
like safety and security, which
sometimes we forget that those
are moral values, right?
Safety and security
are about protecting
things that matter for people.
And so thinking about those as
values that we're committed to
and that we have systems
in place to preserve
is really important.
I think we also
have to recognize
that the other kinds of
attributes that we might have
in play in our decisions,
even things we often
think of as just mechanical
attributes, like speed,
or precision, or efficiency,
that these are values too.
And we have to have them
in the same conversation
with the decisions we're
making about the ethical values
that we're entrusted
with protecting.
Because often, there are some
very challenging trade-offs
that happen between values,
like speed, and efficiency,
and precision, and
other kinds of things
we care about, like fairness,
transparency, and so on.
So I think
understanding that there
are no ethically
neutral decisions that
get made when you're talking
about technologies that shape
people's lives, that influence
the institutions in society,
there's no way to
be ethically neutral
or to detach yourself from
that set of questions.
So you have to just dive
in and try to get it right.
FEI-FEI LI: To embrace it.
SHANNON VALOR: Absolutely.
FEI-FEI LI: Yeah.
So actually, speaking of
practicing these ethical AI
principles, so Tracy, we
rolled out AI principles
earlier this year.
And we together, and
many of our colleagues,
are working hard to
make responsibility
a part of our process.
So I would love for
you to share with us
and share with our partners
and enterprise colleagues
what we are doing.
TRACY FREY: Yeah, sure.
And a lot of it is a
lot of what Shannon
was saying around
starting at the beginning,
and how do we think about
it from the earliest stages?
So within Cloud AI, we've really
taken the responsible use of AI
and made it a goal of
our development process.
And alongside the
AI principles--
that I hope everyone's had
a chance to read, if not,
they're certainly easy
to find on our website--
but alongside those,
we actually did
our own human-centered approach
within Cloud AI to say,
what are the core
values of this group?
These are the set
of humans who are
going to be creating this
technology to use at scale,
so what does this group
care about the most?
What do we think is critical?
And what came out of that was
courage, integrity, compassion,
and impact.
Now, given how rapidly
this market is expanding--
I mean, just even
the size of this room
or the size of this conference,
the level of interest
that we see and how
quickly it's being used--
given that and the fact
that many customers really
need to use their own data as a
part of any deployed solution,
well, that really makes
the assessing of fairness
and ethical impact,
especially at scale
of technology in enterprises,
it makes it really complex.
And so what we've
done is, we've really
committed to evaluating the
work of Cloud AI carefully
and really in depth, with
the goal of aligning it
with those principles, from the
time the development starts,
all the way through
to hearing back
from our customers and partners
when it's out in the world.
FEI-FEI LI: So can
you give us an example
that a current Cloud AI product
that has reflected this?
TRACY FREY: Yeah.
And certainly, I think in terms
of where it is in our product,
we're still at the very
beginning of a lot of this.
But even in AutoML
for example, we
worked really hard to create
an inclusive machine learning
guide that's available now
to all of our customers
who are accessing AutoML.
And we worked hard to
build it into the product.
So as you're building
the model, you
can then reference that guide.
And it's infused in our
documentation, as well.
And then eventually,
we're working hard
on tools and testing of our
own models, to transparency,
and all the kinds of things
that we can offer to you,
the kinds of tools that we can
build to give to our customers
around how they can
assess their own models
and think about what is
in their data already
and how to think about it
from an ethical standpoint.
FEI-FEI LI: Yeah.
One thing-- I think we all
share this experience--
AI is a very nascent technology.
But even with its
nascency, the importance
of fairness and responsible
development and uses
is already very much
important in our products
and on the mind of many people.
So even at Google,
a lot of these
are the first steps we're
taking to make responsible AI
products.
So I want to ask,
back to Shannon,
that you talk about
public trust--
public trust is not something
that should be a goal.
It should be a consequence of
what we do, that we earn that.
You said that.
So you heard from Tracy
that Google is already
starting to take steps on that.
How do we sustain this?
How do we sustain
our AI principles?
And how do we earn this
long-term, especially
technology like AI and many
others changes rapidly?
SHANNON VALOR: Yeah.
And I think that's the key
is to understand that this
is a long game, and
not something that
has a quick, easy technical fix,
or a quick, easy social fix.
And it's also
important to recognize
that technologies evolve,
people evolve with them.
Technologies also influence
other technologies,
interact in surprising
ways sometimes
with other technologies.
It's a complex web that's
constantly shifting,
which means that
to manage what's
going on in that web
in a responsible way,
you have to always be there.
And you have to always
be paying attention.
And you have to be
constantly seeing this
as an unending task,
something that you're not
looking to finish and tie a bow
on, turn your back on, and walk
away, but something
that you're expecting
that the field of interaction
between technology,
and society, and people is
always going to be shifting.
And managing that
in a trustworthy way
is something that will never
stop being our responsibility.
FEI-FEI LI: Yeah.
That's great.
So one last question, Shannon.
So you've been an academician
for most of your life
and working on books, and
theories, and philosophies
of technology ethics.
But now, you're taking a
step into the industry world
and putting all your expertise
and knowledge into practice.
Does that excite you?
SHANNON VALOR: Yeah.
FEI-FEI LI: What do
you feel about it?
SHANNON VALOR: Sure.
Well, I've always been more of
a practice-oriented philosopher
than a theoretician.
That's partly why I came
around to study these topics.
FEI-FEI LI: I didn't
know philosophers are all
practice-oriented.
SHANNON VALOR: We do exist,
practice-oriented philosophers
do exist.
There may be a little
fewer than they should be,
but we're out there.
But you know, I've been
teaching engineers and computer
scientists for over a
decade about these issues
and teaching working
engineers, even,
about how to develop
ethical principles
and apply them in different
professional contexts.
Most of my research
partners are people
who are involved in engineering
and computer science, as well.
So it's an area that
I'm very comfortable in.
But in general, I also
think that if philosophers
aren't available to step up
when society needs them, then
what good are we?
So I'm kind of with
Plato on that one.
Those of you who might have
read "Plato's Republic",
there's this whole thing about
when society needs your help,
you have to put the book down
and step up and do the work.
So I'm excited to be part
of Google's work now.
FEI-FEI LI: Well,
I can tell you,
we are all excited to
be working with you
and getting your advice.
Like you said, it's a long
run, and it's a journey
we're going to share together.
So our time is up.
And I don't think
there's any better
way of ending this session
with the very quote
that Shannon has inspired
me several years ago when
I was in the audience
listening to one of her talks,
is that there is no
independent machine values.
Machine values are human values.
And the technology we
create are eventually
going to be the
technology that's
going to impact all of us,
our communities, our families,
and our future generations.
And we really want to
invite you into this journey
to develop benevolent
and responsible AI.
Thank you, so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]